San Francisco you're executed the minute
you walk out with in cities now at night
I see guys wearing this stuff left and
right they're very brave because you'll
be very careful you have to have
security or you get your arm cut off I
know that can't do it in London there's
many cities New York Beverly Hills San
Francisco you're executed the minute you
walk out with this before we end today I
have to tell you about a new project
I've got one of the biggest challenges I
have is how do I ensure these watches
these are traveling with me a dozen here
and two here every one of these are
insured weather on on the road I created
Wonder care.com to solve for my
collection as it travels all around the
world ware.com check it out